hayet ben and deal est médecin chercheur
en politiques et système de santé il est
aussi vice président de la fédération
nationale de la santé il réside à
larache au maroc route est effectivement
le maroc se surpasser actuellement parmi
les dix premiers pays au monde qui font
vacciner le plus de proportion de
population ceci parce qu on a démarré
même si on a démarré notre vaccination
4,85 semaine après les pays européens on
a pu avancer parce que premièrement il
ya une adhésion de la population du donc
sans hésitation on avait préparé la
population à l'avant s'il y avait aussi
le geste royal qui a reçu droit même si
ce qui est reçu le dha premières doses
pour encourager la population mais aussi
il faut dire que le terrain était
préparée avec toute la logistique et il
était très facile pour un forum marocain
pour aînés résidant au maroc d'obtenir
un rendez vous avec un simple sinistre
avec un self service donc il y avait la
logistique est facile il ya une adhésion
de la population
il ya des personnes qui étaient
disponibles il faut le dire on avait eu
jusqu'à maintenant on a réussi huit
millions et demi de doses de vaccin donc
ces trois facteurs ont fait que le maroc
maintenant il est bien positionnée sur
le sur le sur le schéma de vaccination
internationale
alors nous on a jusqu'à présent on
utilise de vaccins de vaccins sinopharm
donc de la chine et le vaccin
astrazeneca donc aux fortes et
dernièrement le maroc a conclu un accord
avec deux laboratoires us pour donc il
faut pour nous fournir des doses de
vaccin spoutnik
donc ce sont les trois vaccins qu'on
utilise les deux actions connaissent
actuellement un troisième axe est
disponible 5 on va utiliser dans les
semaines
ce sont des trois vaccins qui
nécessitent pas des chaînes de froid
spectaculaire facile à manipuler
l'efficacité la sécurité ça ne pose
aucun problème
et donc ce sont d'avoir des tracks ça
qu'on a pu obtenir
d'ailleurs les contrats ont été signés
au moins 8 et au moins neuf pour les
deux premiers vaccins et dernièrement
pour le vaccin alors les préparatifs
york contre les autres ils ont été faits
depuis les délais les mois d'été
on a préparé un terrain une logistique
pour pouvoir vacciner plus de 600
personnes par jour c'est une population
qui de 36 millions donc les hosties
population qui est jeune
le 31 sur les 36 millions on a comme
objectif de vacciner 80 % de la
population adulte et donc on doit
tourner autour d'un chiffre de 30
millions avocat à vacciner on a préparé
trois mille une station vaccinale 3000
points de vaccination avec des médecins
des infirmiers
il ya des des stations qui sont fixes et
des stations qui sont mobilisés à dire
c'est le vaccin qui va chercher qui va à
l'envers la population on a des
ambulances qui vont chercher les
personnes chez z qui ne peuvent pas se
dépasser et même pour les personnes qui
ne peuvent même pas se passe avec des
avec des ambulances
il ya des équipes médicales qui vont les
voir ces aides les faire des
consultations dans les médicaments et
les vacciner aussi et aussi la
logistique informatique
il suffit au maroc de d'envoyer son
numéro d'identité sur un sms ou sur la
plate forme électronique et on reçoit
élus lieux de vaccination et son bon
niveau exactement pour aller se faire
vacciner
et aussi on a fait des priorisations
comme tout le monde
donc on a commencé par protéger les
personnes des professionnels exposés les
médecins les produits de santé
l'enseignement la sécurité et autres wii
puis les personnes âgées 75 % à 65 % 60
% maintenant elles sont passées à
vacciner les personnes qui ont qui ont
démarré des chroniques indépendamment de
ceux ci a été facilitée par le fait que
la population marocaine et pour cause
aux jeunes donc même avec les 8 millions
de doses mais huit minutes de vidéo de
ce qu'on a on est parvenu jusqu'à
présent à toucher les personnes de moins
de 60 ans et les malades chroniques
indépendamment de leur âge ceci ça a été
pour nous un point positif pour pouvoir
protéger les groupes durable le plus
rapide le plus rapidement possible c'est
vrai aussi mais s'il y avait une
certaine réticence une certaine
réticence ne fait pas une grande
réticence parce qu'il faut dire que faut
rappeler que le maroc est un pays de
vaccinations ou de maroc il a su
toujours depuis les années 80 le réussir
ses campagnes de vaccination on a une
population qui dit rick des enfants qui
sont vaccinées à plus de 95% donc
généralement les relations du maroc avec
le vaccin
c'est du moins voilà sûr mais avec ce
contexte de pandémie avec ce contexte de
crise il y avait une certaine réticence
donc on a commencé à travailler sur la
sauce à préparer l'opinion publique à
expliquer la chose
à suivre la production du vaccin les
essais cliniques dès le départ pour
préparer l'opinion publique
il y avait aussi il faut le dire avec
avec les dernières réticences
il y avait la décision du roi du maroc
de recevoir sa première injection
publiquement et donc ça a été un geste
fort pour qu'on courage et d autres
personnes à se vacciner parce que ça ne
sert à rien d'avoir un très bon vaccin
un très bon vaccin efficace mais ne pas
avoir une adhésion de la population
une épidémie nous conduire ne peut on ne
peut la vaincre c'est que si on a un
vaccin sûr et efficace et l'adhésion de
la population pour pouvoir arriver à une
immunité collective